I think I'm definitely getting other
people reading from that this is like
literally out of all the things I do in
my life that this is my biggest struggle
[Laughter]
yeah here the dentist I need to go can
you send me up can we do the dentist
doctor thing can we can we can we like
really do it yes once a for all yes
because when I die with rotten teeth
it's going to be your fault like getting
prepped for the keynote gonna give a
talk on the current state of opportunity
in the real estate industry that's how I
want to name the keynote babban and I'm
excited about good vibes Vegas gonna
record my audio book finish that off for
all of you because I know you all of you
are getting the antsy so no this is
babban but he gets that every day but
honestly that's my favorite you have to
keep that in the episode babban sorry
d-roc was so well branded that it's
actually babbles two year anniversary
with the team you graduated you rock
that's right one day Babb and you give
you like DB Rockets he's about to kill
you so let's move on it's only so much
that you can listen to somebody like me
pound you and you know you're wrong
every time when I'm like hey stop
blaming somebody out like when I
literally create a framework that is
100% accountability not because of
anything else other than I think it
works like it leads to have I think 100%
accountability leads to happiness if you
think somebody else is in control of you
you're using if you think the president
your parents upbringing your debt if you
think something is in control of you
you're unhappy I don't think that I
think I can move to Sweden I think I can
get a divorce I think I can change my
career I mean that I mean that like I
don't know like I you know so anyway a
lot of people are navigating their lives
through
using excuses to cope yeah and then I
come along and I'm like not true and
you're like that I need I need it to be
true but you don't get it Gary my dad
molested me
cool , and a lot of people have been
molested unfortunately and like a lot of
them have gone on to achieve like it's
really kind of it's difficult it's
difficult when I'm putting out content
like your problems your mother and like
you're not doing things cuz your mother
didn't raise you well and you're
pandering to her
that's not consumable content then I
curse then I'm alpha so there's a lot of
reasons not to hang around but the good
part is I don't want everybody right I
only want people matter for everybody I
want people who want to win and like
good things I get my emails I get every
day of something happened I mean the guy
on the escalator now is like you're the
reason my wife gets out of bed I started
getting out of bed you know what kind of
impact that is that's far more exciting
to me than telling you exactly how to
plan a Facebook ad on a white paper with
a marker of their 100% because that's
[ __ ] real [ __ ]
[Applause]
thank you so much
thank you thank you I like your pink
hair I'm always listening
good morning remax how are you so
impressed with this turnout because I
was in Toronto yesterday and I flew in
pretty late and when I was walking from
check-in to my room I saw a lot of you
getting very ridiculous I'm putting out
a podcast every day and trying to bring
value not sell you into my funnel not
get you to sign up for my thing and so
bringing value thus I have his attention
which is remarkably valuable could be
even the reason I'm back could be I
don't know good it is
I made a shitload of money because of my
podcast right I mean you have to
understand you have to understand right
now there is nobody dominating the top
200 in the real estate sector in podcast
everybody here has the chance tomorrow
to start a podcast that's evergreen what
happens in real estate which is what
happens in so many other industries is
we default into selling too much and not
enough into branding I love selling let
me tell you the best way to sell in the
world have the customer come to you
without you doing anything you didn't
buy your Nikes I would argue that
everybody in this audience right now
bought 85 to 90% of the clothes they're
wearing right now because of brand not
because of sales I need everybody to
look at this babban where you get up
here actually you know what Stan don't I
know some of you retired last night I
saw you please keep standing I need to
make a piece of content give me one
second
Davin get over here just keep standing
please stand if you mainly watch Netflix
Instagram guess what all these people
standing which is like
percent of the audience mainly only
watched Netflix our people really
watching commercials
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much
how are you answer pleasure to meet a
melon one Chilean screaming out there
I'm one of the younger guys over here in
the Portland area when I started with
three that's five months ago
Latinos five homes so far I got to drive
I already know the man who's literally
who who's putting out that podcast every
day getting yeah I just want a picture
with you you gotta to contribute stuff
but you know I was just listening to a
thing that you just posted about your
anniversary for Wine Library yessuf and
how you just went out had your team pick
up a camera sat down showed that little
clip that you just making this video and
I just started doing local videos like
in my editor mine it just made me laugh
so hard cause like my first video is me
just sitting like a weirdo yep and it's
the most worst video I've ever made and
you have been enjoying your life sipping
the syrup and the line in Norway taking
whatever you touch the sword of the
wicked is comfortable Oh
[Music]
hello men do you know a page we're on
yesterday Lance told me 16 did you just
see what you did yeah
you literally just drilled that bro that
was so weird
Greg you talked to a mom in there
there's something you should know right
this minute I have around 500 DMS from
people who want something from me you
know what I have to say to them Mazel
Tov and go away and that's if I'm in a
good mood or I'm trying to be nice
why would I encourage you to try to get
other influencers attention when I
ignore or reject the majority of people
who try this tactic with me because if
they were doing it right
I wouldn't reject them if I felt they
weren't just trying to use me if I
thought they were just genuinely trying
to be helpful if they could recognize a
hole in my business and the knowledge if
they could recognize a hole in my
business and have the knowledge and
skills to fill it I might consider
talking to them when you can't offer
exposure or money what do you have
knowledge and skill do you want a pizza
shop could you offer free pizza from
your shop for six months are you graphic
designer could you offer to make 600
custom filters do you own a liquor store
as soon as your targets post shots of
themselves enjoying wine you could
direct message them with an offer for a
free case of wine for the month or for
the rest of the year
PS New Jersey laws don't allow this but
other states do otherwise I'll be doing
this with my family business people will
tell you not to sell yourself cheap but
you can stand on that principle only
when you have people willing to buy what
you're selling for a perfect example of
how to do this right read d-roc story in
Chapter three of my book askgaryvee or
you can hear his version of the story in
my medium peace how I got my job formed
Gary Boehner
you getting stuck I see feet in the mud
you weapon caught in the flood cause the
water is imparted we run we push you
sold out harvesters us you have been
enjoy your life sipping the syrup and
aligned in no way taking whatever you
touch disorder the wicked is cope with
them done
welcome to the city it announced a
special mr. peace we can 5 interfere at
a shotgun